[Musique]
avec surprise je n'attends rien cette
présélection
en revanche je suis touché et heureuse
d'en faire partie c'est fabuleux
heureusement c'est génial moi je
n'oublie pas d'où je viens donc c'est
quelque chose d'extraordinaire mais m
c'est terrifiant du football champagne
pour comme on peut pas rêver mieux à
part gagner je pense après c'est pas une
fin en soi quand on fait un film on
cherche pas spécialement aller aux
césars mais c'est toujours bien qu'on
reconnaisse notre travail continue de me
révéler et j'ai pris de l'âge ans
espérait devenir un parent non je suis
toujours une révélation
j'en suis très content j'ai vécu
merveilleusement réseau non j'en suis
fier je suis très ému en fait sur un
ring non mais je suis ravie je suis
hyper heureuse c'est bien mais je fais
confiance à ma bonne étoile mais on est
cinq filles normalement l'en n'est que
trois monts l'est représentent elles
sont avec nous par texto on leur envoie
des photos elle mérite tout autant
d'être là parce que c'est des grandes
comédiennes
j'étais content et puis je me suis
aujourd'hui surtout dit aussi que le
film avait eu une portée beaucoup de
plus grandes que ce qu'on espérait que
c'est aussi pour ça que moi j'avais pu
être mis un plan lumière
je suis très heureux très honoré d'être
là je prends ça comme un encouragement
comme une reconnaissance je voyais ça
vraiment comme l'espèce des toiles qui
est très très très très haut et pour l'
envie d'essayer à tout prix de le
toucher un sou
extraordinaire est impressionnant mais
c'est vrai je me cache pas mais ça va
bien se passer
j'ai fait me l'aller retour dans ma tête
je peux vous dire je m'y attendais pas
du tout parce que forcément on y pensait
et ça allait pas être un drame si j
étais pas mais c'est une grande joie d'y
être c est le moment le plus émouvant d
des césars en fait vivre ça avec des
amis avec avec toute cette équipe on est
devenus très proches donc c'est
merveilleux c'est un film qui parle de
femmes de combat de femmes au quotidien
c'est un hommage à tous ces gens qui ont
perdu la vie et qui sont battus pour
pauvres pour une algérie libre et je
suis vraiment heureuse d'être ici pour
le film de céline que j'aime énormément
qui est vraiment beau qui j'aime
beaucoup ce qu'ils véhiculent aussi et
je suis très content du parcours du film
j'ai senti à la lecture du scénario que
qu'on avait un film fort le regard de
mounia était si beau que je sentais un
peu qui se passait quelque chose j'avoue
je vais pas mentir j'ai l'impression
d'avoir fait un devoir de mémoire
parce que ces histoires de mes parents
ce qui est important c'est les films qui
restent et les choix qu'on fait et je
trouve que pour le coup les misérables
c'est un pink est nécessaire qui est
chargée d'espoir qui aspire à la
réflexion et cambrai c'est ça le plus
important
je partis en jean claude van damme
[Musique]
fèvre je suis très touché que des jeunes
générations tout d'un coup j'ai envie
d'être épaulé par un fouteur de merde
comme moi à anthony c'est un très très
très grand travailleur hors du commun
c'est un talent mais il est un diamant
brut
timothée est un lecteur qui
s'improvisent avec le film puisque lille
et perche man 2
de formation et qu'il est très bon comme
quoi pas besoin de faire du
conservatoire
parfois c'est un peu rageant très
admirative d'abord du film et de ce
qu'elle a fait dans film si jeune et
avoir autant de force et de
détermination quand tu mets en avant des
jeunes acteurs qui du coup sont venus
par la profession comme des révélations
et d'espoir pour l'avenir bas pour nous
pour les réalisateurs c'est le plus beau
des cadeaux ce que plaisir en plus on
les aime bien en vrai en vrai ils sont
sympa en plus je le remercie déjà tous
les jours puisque j'ai passé des bêtes
de moments c'était un pur kif
d'abord il est acteur au départ pas
seulement dans hors normes il fait du
théâtre qui fait la danse ça a été
magnifique la route ça a été magnifique
lot tournage et je trouve ça magnifique
les de ce soir qui soit une révélation
aux césars 2020 et à est mon ami depuis
dix ans et qu'elle c'est une amitié qui
m'est absolument précieuse j'ai vraiment
un trouvé qu'elle était exceptionnel
dans le film et je suis très fier d'elle
j'ai choisi adel bat pour son élégance
sa liberté son parcours et plein
d'autres choses
je suis dure choisie par des gens que
j'aime elle représente le parcours idéal
d'une actrice libre elle peut me faire
pleurer et me faire et en même temps
c'est ce que j'attends du cinéma c'est
juste d'avoir des émotions donc que
mademoiselle nina meurisse mais proposé
de l'accompagner
je me suis dit waouh waouh abasourdi par
sa capacité d'incarnation donc je pense
que c'est une grande actrice
c'est incroyable j'ai pas que tu as 12
septembre
le début c'est génial je lis tu mérites
un césar je te dis merci
[Musique]